cette femme que vous voyez chapelle abir
moussi elle est à la tête du parti des
citoyens libres qui prône un retour à un
régime fort d'ailleurs regarder à côté
d'elle c'est une photo de bourguiba le
prédécesseur de ben ali son parti est
aujourd'hui dans les intentions de vote
la première force politique en tunisie
et de loin il y à une nostalgie qui
s'est emparé d'une partie de la tunisie
le souffle démocratique né après la
révolution est retombé et dix ans après
l'heure est à la comparaison avec la
situation d'avant 2010 c'est l'objet de
ce nouveau numéro de facture c'est dans
cette petite ville sidi bouzid que tout
a commencé
pas que la révolution tunisienne mais
bien ce qu'on a appelé les printemps
arabes
le 16 décembre 2010 un chômeur qui
vendait des légumes pour survivre se
fait confisquer sa marchandise par la
police puis s'immole par le feu de
désespoir les émeutes éclatent
moins d'un mois plus tard zine el
abidine ben ali en fuite en arabie
saoudite après 23 ans de pouvoir sans
partage
c'est le début d'une longue séquence
d'instabilité politique il y a eu de
très nombreuses manifestations le retour
de partis islamistes dans le paysage
politique
il ya eu d assassinat aussi l'élection
d'une assemblée constituante chargée de
rédiger une nouvelle constitution qui
sera finalement voté le 26 janvier 2014
dans la foulée la première
présidentielle au suffrage universel
direct depuis la révolution remporté par
béji caïd essebsi l'homme décède le 25
juillet 2019 déclenchant de nouvelles
élections qui voit la victoire d'un
conservateur indépendant raïs sayyed
entre temps la participation est passée
de 62 9% à 48 9% et quant à ben ali
il est décédé le 19 septembre 2019 en
arabie saoudite
dans les rues de sidi bouzid dix ans
après le portrait du vendeur ambulant
mohamed bouazizi s'affiche en grand sur
la façade du bâtiment de la poste
mais l'heure est plutôt au bilan et la
révolution a comme un goût amer elle a
été à la hauteur des attentes
non pas du tout et là on voit cinq ans
voilà cinq cibles de chiffres montrent
cette gueule de bois
le taux de chômage déjà qui a augmenté
de plusieurs points et d'après le centre
national de la statistique tunisien le
pouvoir d'achat qui a régressé d'environ
4% entre 2011 et 2018 alors qu'il a
enregistré une hausse de 20 % entre 2002
et 2011
vous n'avez pas tout par enchantement on
dira l'espèce d'illumination collective
mais comment de façon à produire chacun
à penser à soi vous avez les amis les et
les administrations ont eu des
revendications séparatistes et les
avocats des sables images histoire et
les médecins des petits est en fait la
solution machin là issus et l'achat de
la paix sociale est passée en grande
partie par le recrutement dans la
fonction publique
l'antre 2011 la fonction publique a
doublé et donc ça a doublé et ça avait
rêvé le budget n'est pas du clientélisme
et du corporatisme qui sont bien
visibles au niveau politique où la
libération d'expression c'est seul
départ a mené par piment parlementaire
en dizaines de partis au législatif de
aucune majorité claire n'a émergé cette
partie a obtenu plus de cent mille voix
et l'hémicycle du palais du bardo a
maintenant autant de couleurs qu'un
étals de marchands classe en septembre
2020 cet homme hichem mechiche y est
désigné par le président ça y est tu
pour former un nouveau gouvernement avec
une seule idée en tête en finir avec les
querelles politiciennes
du moment où on n'est pas partie
prenante à oka aucun tiraillements
politiques a aucun à aucun engagement
politique aux politiciens je pense que
nous pouvons atteindre des résultats et
je pense que nous pouvons aussi emmener
les les toute la classe politique avec
nous du moment où ils sont conscients et
sont certains que nous sommes pas partis
dans des dans des conflits politiques
ce qui est intéressant c'est que deux
écosystèmes politiques très différents
ont tous les deux montré leur
inefficacité avant la concentration des
pouvoirs entre les mains d'un seul homme
benali et d'un seul clan autour de lui
sclérosé la société tunisienne et
aujourd'hui ce sont les querelles entre
les multitude de partis politiques au
sein du parlement qui conduisent tôt
même immobilisme en à une transition qui
sait qu'une question qui fait qu on est
passé d'un régime politique autoritaire
avec le régime hyperprésidentiel avec
feux de société civile ou à un compte
allemand contrôlé par l'état tu as une
parano des citoyens sert à quelque chose
traînant mais il n'y a pas eu de
transformation ne l'est pas et donc on
se retrouve avec un régime politique qui
est de fait démocratique mais le
problème c'est qu'il ya une inertie
administrative telle et il ya tellement
le pouvoir est tellement dispersé que
c'est difficile aussi par des réformes
et les espoirs perdus de la révolution
créé aussi des pertes de repères et donc
pour certains une nostalgie et la
tentation d'un retour vers l'ancien
régime
pour d'autres c'est l'exil le nombre de
départs clandestins est en hausse
constante depuis 2015 pour une poignée
de tunisiens aussi c'est le pire qui a
été choisi selon les estimations de
l'onu entre 3000 et 5000 auraient
rejoint les rangs de dèche en syrie et
en irak depuis les défaites de l'état
islamique au levant les craintes sont
fortes d'un retour des combattants vers
les rives tunisienne ou plusieurs
attentats ont été perpétrés depuis 2015